[Music]  the Broadway community is rallying  around actress Ruthie animiles  after she and her four-year-old daughter  Abigail bloom enstein were involved in a  fatal crash in Brooklyn on Monday  Abigail and another child were killed in  the crash and Ruthie who is pregnant is  currently in the hospital the New York  Police Department tells ET a driver  allegedly struck Ruthie her daughter and  three other pedestrians after running a  red light no arrests have been made and  the investigation into the incident is  ongoing a GoFundMe page has been set up  for Ruthie and it claims she is in  critical condition I am profoundly  grateful for everything this this  recognition has meant  Ruthie won a Tony for her work in the  2015 revival of the King and I  [Music]  she was set to reprise her award-winning  role in London this spring  you